[Music]
to my view a lot of our contemporary
political crisis derives from an
abandonment of the idea of moral
progress so when the country was founded
in the 18th century it its framers
subscribed to an idea that progress is
moral and the that idea of progress came
from Christianity that pilgrims progress
is a journey from sin to salvation
enlightenment philosophers like the guys
drafted the founding documents the
United States didn't share that
necessarily share that particular
Christian notion of a journey from sin
to salvation but they understood
progress and the United States and its
founding as an experiment would lead to
political progress because it would was
designed to improve the lives of the
most people that people would act with
in a sense of a common endeavor as a
republic that our obligations would be
to one another in a form of community
and then we should understand
achievement as moral progress that
changed over the course of the 19th
century when progress came to have a
real technological cast think about the
railroad the telegraph the camera people
began to think about progress as
advancing like a train on a linear track
and each machine would make the world
better because things would go faster
and goods would become cheaper and very
quickly that idea of moral progress was
replaced by progress as prosperity so if
you were asking how are things going for
the country where the country is
prospering we have made progress and the
slippage from we've made a more just
society to certain people a lot of
people are making a lot of more a lot
more money and a lot of goods are
cheaper for people to buy that's a real
slippage right so you then in the 20th
century progress is even sort of less
new forms of production and accelerated
production but accelerated consumption
so the more people are buying the more
goods people have like the standard of
living is rising therefore we we have
progress um and in the second half of
the 20th century the idea that there
even is progress especially
technologically driven
US begins to fall apart because of
Hiroshima so people look at the world
with what's technological progress
gotten us in the middle of the century
we have built a bomb that can destroy
the whole planet and by the 1950s we're
destroying the environment and it may be
possible that human life cannot live on
this planet indefinitely under these
circumstances or even for the next
several centuries right so there's a
real crisis in the idea of progress by
the time you get to the 1980s and 1990s
there's a new generation of
technological utopians and they start
talking about innovation as progress
innovation historically as a word means
progress without any concern for
morality innovation in 18th century
sense is bad innovation is novelty for
its own sake like just invent it and who
cares what the consequences are
innovation historically is actually
quite a dreadful and damning thing to
accuse somebody if you're innovating is
a very grave accusation so by the 1980s
there's such a kind of reckless
heedlessness in American businesses and
it's the kind of the great that sort of
mergers age they kind of like a wall
street grub enos kind of like that
Michael Douglas movie moment right like
the greed is good kind of thing that
innovation this innovations Heelys
innovation is fine because this is how
this creative destruction is you know
this junk term that gets recycled is the
engine of economic growth and nothing
else matters the public good moral
integrity decency goodness for more
people the health of the Republic all
that matters is is it innovative is it
is it is and then by the 1990s is it
disruptively innovative which is even
more radically innovative but it that it
disrupts existing models of business and
disrupts existing industries and so you
get this real embrace of heedlessness as
an American value or as a corporate
value which is a complete abdication of
the spirit of progress right and it also
it's also designed the whole ideology it
really is like a religion it's very
culty the idea of disruptive innovation
it's designed to refute its own critics
designed to refuse critics because among
its principles is that the past doesn't
matter no one should ever study history
or care about the past because if you're
gonna be a disruptive innovator if all
that matters is novelty you don't want
to know if you're gonna you know to
invent a new ride service you shouldn't
study taxi dispatch because it will
interfere with the creative destruction
that you're capable of and it will limit
your vision and it will make your
disruptive innovation insufficiently
innovative and insufficiently disruptive
so you have to abdicate the path there
is no concern with the past people want
to criticize you for failing oh no
failure is actually a virtue of
disruptive innovation it's a cuttance a
very self-contained explanation that in
my view introduces an extraordinary
amount of disequilibrium into a
political system that is a republic that
is actually designed on the idea that in
in many ways businesses have to have the
public interest at heart because the
government is protecting their their
capacity to do business by creating
civil order and safety for the
transportation of goods and government
provides all kinds of services that make
it possible for businesses to thrive
there for businesses to have to be
concerned with a healthy social and
political order with you know avoiding
wild inequalities of wealth and income
with avoiding wild political turbulence
but disruptive innovation isn't
concerned with any of those things
disruptive innovation is concerned with
blowing things up
[Music]
you